well obviously the tournament is getting
stronger every year right and every year
we have a new champion so it's very
exciting and you know it's a new
challenge every year that's a cool part
about it in my opinion this is one of
the toughest u.s. women's championship
field we don't have anyone much lower
rated than anyone else anymore it's a
close call
I think this year anyone can win I think
it's a good thing that tournaments
getting stronger there isn't as much
pressure to win every single game
because when there was only two people
who are beating everyone in every drawer
every loss that means basically a
tournament is over so I think it's
better to have a more even feel it's
really great that to see a lot of
youngsters coming into US Championship
every year and being willing to not just
play in the tournament but actually win
it so I think it it gives us great hope
that US chess is getting stronger and
stronger and we might look at some
future contenders for the world title
hopefully soon so it's great to see
fighting spirit especially in young
girls tournaments a really great
opportunity for like someone like me
who's like younger to gain experience by
playing at some of the older players and
I really like how the tournament's been
getting stronger over the years because
I think it shows a lot about how
American chess is like improving over
time the tournament is it's really
strong it's the strongest closed round
rubbing that I've ever played I think
everybody is coming really prepared and
it's it's a really great opportunity for
anybody to play and issues more younger
people are playing so it's a it's kind
of interesting they played quite well
and they just don't they don't see us
all that rich look at this so strong
they are much higher rated they're
trying their best chess and I think this
is also very good it's good experience
for them it's good training for future
chess Olympics they will probably
represent our country because me and
Irina we will not play forever